first joining us now with reaction to
the ongoing Panic inside the Democratic
party is Texas Senator Ted Cruz Senator
you know there's a lot at stake here I
mean look at the borders a disaster look
at the economy it's a disaster I have
more bad news we have predictions JP
Morgan Chase that we they think a barrel
of oil is going to a dollar fifty when
you lose these top Democrats in the
media that is that is the canary in the
coal mine now if the media and prominent
Democrats start sounding like me on
Biden family corruption you'll know the
gig is up for Joe would you agree
I I would I think Democrats are are
fleeing the ship like rats and and I
think they're they're scared they're
looking at Joe Biden and listen they've
got a structural problem if you're a
Democrat running for reelection in 2024
you can't run on their record you can't
run on jobs you can't run on the economy
you certainly can't run on inflation you
can't run on crime you can't run on
immigration with the chaos at the
southern border you can't run on foreign
policy with the largest land war in in
Europe since World War II you can't run
on standing with the military with a
disgraceful surrender to the Taliban in
Afghanistan every enemy of America has
gotten stronger every enemy of America
has been abandoned and and more than
two-thirds of Americans recognize that
bidenomics and by the way how much does
the White House regret naming it by
Dynamics bidenomics has made life harder
for working men and women if you're a
senior and you go go buy food at the
store you pay your bills you pay your
rent you pay your electricity the cost
of everything's gone up it's harder and
harder to make ends meet young people
coming out of school who are discovering
they can't pay their rent they can't pay
their car payment and it and God forbid
you try to buy a house and you pay
interest rate rates that have doubled
and tripled since Joe Biden was elected
and so if you're a Democrat you can't
run on record what do you do you have to
run on attacking Donald Trump that's the
only note they have is yes our guy's a
train wreck but we think the other guy's
worse and and so Sean here's what I
predict and this is something I said
last week on my podcast verdict with Ted
Cruz I think the odds are very
significant that next summer at the
Democrat National Convention that the
Democrat Party will jettison Joe Biden
will throw him off the ticket and they
will parachute in instead Michelle Obama
to be their candidate I think they're
going to look to Michelle Obama as the
Savior to come in and and I think if
that happens that would be very very
dangerous and every time I see a
Democrat or one of their puppets in the
Press beginning to point out the
problems with Joe Biden every time that
happens the chances of that go up and up
and up do you see Michelle Obama wanting
that
you know I don't know I don't know
Michelle very well I've met her but I
don't know her well but but here's my
thinking on this if Joe Biden were out
of the ticket there'd be a bunch of
Republicans running you you would have
the top four I think would be Kamala
Harris Pete bootage Elizabeth Warren and
Gavin Newsom I think that'd be the top
tier and I think they'd fight like crazy
in an Open Primary I actually think in
that primary I think Elizabeth Warren
wins because I think Elizabeth Warren is
the closest to the ID of the Democrat
Party it's it's where they are you think
about it in 2020 you had Elizabeth
Warren and Bernie Sanders splitting the
crazy left-wing socialist Moon bat Lane
of the Democrat Party If Warren runs
this time she'll dominate that lane now
the problem is if you're a Democrat who
wants to win that scares you you look at
Kamala Harris and kamala's numbers are
worse than Joe Biden's that scares you
and so I think as they're thinking about
it who you could put in if the Democrats
pick any of those four you tick off the
other three and risk alienating their
supporters I think Michelle Obama brings
the Obama pedigree she parachutes in
with also the suit of armor of a first
lady with high positives and relatively
low negatives and I think they can
justify to everyone who gets snubbed
well look we went with Michelle Obama
instead I don't know if she wants it but
I do think it would be much more
attractive to her to come in next summer
and just campaign a couple of months to
the general rather than having to spend
two years campaigning vigorously on the
ground let me ask you now that his
cognitive decline seems to have
significantly worsened and it is that
condition would be degenerative you
don't get better you're only going to
get worse I mean it was an awful week
last week forever not a good week uh
weekend as well when you couple that
with the horrific economy that we have
now now we see inflation roaring back
that's not good now we'll see record gas
prices now we're going one to four or
five dollars a gallon again you look at
the border chaos it's never been this
bad every year becomes a new record and
they they can lie all they want and say
the border is secure it's not secure the
border is closed it's not closed they're
just lying about it high cost energy
horrible economy horrible foreign policy
paying rents of now to Iran just one
example I mean can anybody
with with there was that many strikes
again against them if peace and
prosperity drive all elections can they
win
well they can't win on the traditional
test the standard way to run is to say
are you better off than you were four
years ago and for virtually everyone in
America the answer to that is no unless
you happen to be a Mexican drug boss
unless you happen to be a tech Kingpin
the answer is no your life is not better
under Joe Biden and so if they can't run
on their record they have to run on
scaremongery they have to run on saying
Donald Trump is the embodiment of evil
and it's all they can do and look you
talk about mental decline listen Joe
Biden in the last two and a half years
they hide him in the basement every day
we sit around so Senate Republicans we
have lunch together every Tuesday
Wednesday and Thursday and we sit around
at lunch and talk about the fact how
none of us have spoken to Joe Biden
since he became president I haven't said
a word to him since he became president
now you might say Okay Cruz is a right
winger well you're in my friend Lindsey
Graham hasn't spoken to Biden since he
became president and Joe and Lindsay
traveled all over the world together
they've been buddies for 20 years the
White House keeps them in the basement
because he is not up to talking with us
and I got to say it is disconcerting you
know you know Sean it reminds me I saw a
bumper sticker this summer and the
bumper sticker said Joe Biden is not an
idiot
Joe Biden has dementia the people who
voted for him are the idiots there's a
lot of Truth to that of look and it's
one thing if you did it the first time
if you did it the first time where the
campaign was we're going to go back to
yesteryear to a Kinder gentler world
where things will be fine and some
people found that attractive well at
this point you've seen the train train
wreck I can't tell you how many voters
I've talked to how many I've heard from
who say wow I I thought I didn't like
where things were but they are so much
worse now people who voted for Joe Biden
who are regretting it as they're seeing
how their life is worse and so I think
that's one of the reasons why more and
more Democrats are getting nervous and
wanting to jettison Biden all together
all right Senator Cruz thank you hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else